Two guys are sitting together in a bar
in the remote Alaskan wilderness arguing
about the existence of God. While they're
old friends they have very different
ideas on God: one is a priest and the
other is an atheist. The atheist says
"Look it's not like I haven't given God a
chance, I've even tried the prayer thing.
It didn't work!" The priest asks with some
incredulity: "Did you really pray? When did
this happen?"
"Just last month" replies the atheist "I
got caught away from the camp and a
terrible blizzard I was totally lost and
I couldn't see a thing it was 20 degrees
below zero and so I prayed I fell to my
knees in the snow and cried out: Oh God
if there is a god I'm lost in this
blizzard and I'm going to die if you
don't help me!" the priest looks at the
atheist puzzled and says: "Well, then you
must believe in God now, after all here
you are, alive!" The atheist rolls his eyes
and replies: "No, no that's not how it
happened! A couple of Eskimos came
wandering by and showed me the way back
to the camp". So, where do such different
perspectives come from? Confirmation bias
is a tendency to look for, interpret and
recall information in ways that affirm
our preconception. Whenever we encounter
objective facts on an issue we look at
them through the lens of our own beliefs.
As a result we see and overrate where
the to intercept. The bias is strongest
for emotionally charged issues or when
we search for desired outcomes.
Wrapped inside popular narratives,
cultural beliefs and family values a
confirmation bias often gets passed on
for generations. The priest learned from
his ancestors that God is behind
everything. The atheist was raised within
a family that believed only in
scientific knowledge. When we are
confronted with unfamiliar or new
situations a bias helps us to draw
fast conclusions. If every encounter with
a stranger would require us to think of
all sorts of possible outcomes, we would
not come to any conclusions. Economically
speaking it would be too costly. To
survive in a dangerous world we learn to
operate like storytelling,
pattern-seeking animals, each one of us
thinking that our story and our head is
the right one. Today we can afford to
slow down and think more deeply about
certain issues. When we do this we can
become aware of our own biases. We begin
to realize that things are often more
complicated than we thought.
Psychologist Peter Cathcart Wason who
coined the term confirmation bias left
us with this fun little hypothesis rule
discovery task, let's see if you can do
it? What's the rule behind the sequence
of numbers: 2 4 6 ? And what comes next?
Write the correct number and the rule we
are looking for in the comments below!
Now, fast!
Psychologists and nobel prize winner
Daniel Kahneman said: "A reliable way to
make people believe in falsehoods is
frequent repetition. Because familiarity
is not easily distinguished from truth.".
Which means if there is time to reflect
slowing down is likely to be a good idea!
if you like this video and the way we
explain the subject subscribe to our
channel we try to explain complex
subjects in simple language and cartoons
to support students all around the world
in their learning if you want to support
us you can go to WWE and calm sprouts
and donate just $1 from many fans makes
a big difference
you